let's move on to audio here's a little
bit trickier you need to know a few more
things to work out the file size of you
know say a piece of music or sound and
see how good your memory is what are the
different bits and pieces I'll give you
a clue to start with the first two
things you need to know and there's
blood too
the first two things you need to do I'm
an audiophile correspond to these two
things here
bit depth and resolution okay bit depth
says how much data for each bit and
resolution is how many in total so
what's the first one
okay all right now actually hmm I hope
it does something right you do need the
sample right let's just remember what
that means that means that every second
right what we hear that guy is what we
hear is continuous sound right but a
computer can't record continuous now
because digital right so what has to do
is record distinct sounds many many
times per second and then play them all
at once and fools are either the
thinking it's a continuous sound right
so that's what sample raters and that's
measured in Hertz okay a thousand Hertz
would be a thousand measurements every
single second okay all right now we
actually missed the two things that
correspond to earlier right we set up
for an image you need bit depth right
you also need bit depth for an audio
file as well and they'll tell you not
how many colors you can different colors
you now but how many different kinds of
sounds that you have and corresponding
to resolution which is how many pixels
total right what would correspond to
that from where fun
resolution just tells you okay how many
pixels have I got right
how BIG's the picture mean what
corresponds to that for a song is how
long it is right so three minutes three
minutes half an hour lake do you need to
do that to work outside now one two
three we're missing one more thing that
we need to know about this audio file to
be able to work out how big it is
starting to see and don't be is really
famous for it
sort of
yeah okay
we're we're thinking about we're trying
to think about I compressed audio
compression it's actually it's really
important to know but because it's too
complicated to work out we sort of just
let you off you don't to worry about it
okay um the other thing that we need to
know the fourth thing that starts with C
is the number of channels do you
remember what channels are channels
right so that's different directions
that the sound comes from and each one
has to be stored indistinctly right so
for instance in this room you have two
speakers right and we call that stereo
if you've only got one speaker or you've
got two speakers outputting the same
sound what we call that mono one channel
two channels you can have ball which is
often called multi-track or surround
sound is the mystic Kabat example so
surround sound is like 5.1 you know 5.1
surround what does that mean does anyone
know how many channels this 5.1 surround
sound seeks you the seeks right ah
you've got if you picture a room okay
what you got is a main speaker at the
front which is kind of like right then
in theory you'll bear to have four
satellites around the edges which tend
to be sort of smaller speakers that are
you know said you know someone's behind
you in this direction that kind of thing
and then the point one is a it's kind of
like a sort of at the front usually but
it's a sub woofer that product per ounce
of eight base there right and all these
other ones it can't really the size of a
speaker if you remember we watch that
video that tells you how speakers
actually work produce you know frequency
changes and that kind of thing
the bigger the speaker is the deeper the
sound it can man so these four speakers
at the edges in particular to be very
small that's why they call satellites
but this subwoofer threads is big heavy
box okay so that's the point one so you
got six channels it okay now how do we
use that to work out afar sighs well if
we do all of these things we can work
out actually not just file size
but sometimes what you will be asked to
calculate is called bit rate now that's
a bit confusing
it sounds like bit death it's not bit
death I would get to a bit rate in a
second after we do with far side okay so
let's consider an example okay so a
sample rate does anyone know what's the
most common sample rate out there it's a
really strange random number yeah it's
yeah that's the right numbers yeah add a
couple of zeros so cd-quality audio is
forty-four thousand one hundred Hertz
which is quite astonishing when you
think about it but our ears are capable
of discerning you know that's a lot of
silence per second every second so
there's my sample rate bit death what's
a common bit death well 16 bit is pretty
kind just like with bit depth of heart
right the more colors you have
eventually about human I can't
distinguish between all these different
colors and like I don't know they open
it's like blue and blue I don't know no
same thing this sounds most people's
ears can't really tell that much
difference above 16 bit okay link just
say I don't know four minutes on ok and
how many channels let's just make it
stereo because that's what most music is
so how would we work out the size of
such a file let's work it out in
megabytes ok how do we do it just like
before
I don't have to go down yeah to avoid my
surrounds now take your hurts right that
means every second you've got one of
these signals
how big is each signal it'll be 16 bits
in size okay
how many signals you have for every
moment every every one of your
recordings you got two one for the left
and one for the right don't give that
right for us we have left and right okay
so multiply that by two and then just
like I had 2048 by 1536 is how many
pixels I had and to know how many
seconds do I have because this is per
second so I'm gonna convert well how
many do I have four minutes and each
minute has 60 seconds in it okay so
that's gonna be the number of bits
that's gonna be a really big number
all right okay so how do I convert
number one let's get it into bytes
okay so I divide by 8 then I want to
convert it into megabytes so before we
did kilobytes that's 1,024 to go again
another stage two megabytes you divide
by a thousand of 24 squared okay which
is actually 1,048,576 so you can write
that down that's your answer for stop
okay alright now again you can get your
calculator work that out you don't need
to that's the full answer but I'm gonna
move on because we're running out of
time I said you can also calculate not
just a fall size total file size which
is that thing but you can also work out
a bit right now what does that mean okay
that's super duper visors it means that
every second every second how many bits
does the file take up for every second
of sound so you might recognize kilobits
we did under communications justice
because it tends to be come here the
unit we use money for trans in your CDs
so it's a transfer rate okay so for
instance you might have seen if you like
last stuff on I
I tease or something they're like oh
it's 128 kilobits right more kilo bits
per second that means more higher audio
quality doesn't tell you specifically
which parts but yeah the idea so how do
I work out bit rate it's going to be in
kilo bits per second note that okay so
what you want to figure out is okay
every second I've got this many signals
right every signal is going to be that
big okay and I've got how these sets of
those signals well I had a left and a
right okay now I leave off this bit at
the end because this is interested in
the total right but this is just
interested in each individual second I
don't care how many seconds there are so
that's why I leave that part out now if
I want to convert that to not mega bytes
per second but kilo bits be careful
right I'm not gonna divide by eight
because that was conveying two bytes
here do you remember what we were
talking about trans India receiving
right this is confusing I know but kilo
bits per second the kilo here doesn't
mean a thousand 24 it just means a
thousand okay
come in muddy so you work that out and
that'll be your number for the Q bits
per second for well for CB CD audio
that's uncompressed okay and I'll just
say I am actually
this number means therefore every second
of audio on that CD it takes up that
many bits okay every single second